joining us on the line first is larry
elder longtime friend he is host of the
talk show the larry elder show author of
the best-selling book the ten things you
can't say in America his latest
documentary Uncle Tom explores what it's
like to be a minority within a minority
a black conservative Larry gonna talk
user good talk to YouTube and thank you
so much for having me I appreciate it
you bet so watching all of these
protests move forward I've been saying
over and over it feels like most
Americans agree on a few basic things
police brutality is bad racism is bad
and rioting and looting are bad and yet
somehow we are now fighting over the
basic idea that rioting and looting
might be okay that actually police
brutality is inherently racism and that
racism is not only widespread in police
departments across the United States but
that America at root is a racist country
that must be punished for its sins
that's what the kneeling seems like how
do you interpret the process
well I interpret the same way you do I
mean it's outrageous look the idea that
the police are out to get black people
is simply not borne out by the facts if
that were the case maybe I'd be down
there with them picketing as well it's
just not true it's been studied many
times there's a Harvard economist named
rollin flyer and he found out that the
police not only were not using deadly
force disproportionately against black
people but that the police were more
hesitant more reluctant to pull the
trigger on a black person than a white
person he happened to be black he said
it was the most surprising finding of
his career because intuitively he just
knew that all these stories about
Freddie gray and Eric Gardner suggested
that there was a deep deep seeded
problem and he found that it wasn't the
case there is another study that was
done published in a publication put out
by the National Academy of Sciences when
they looked at every police shooting in
2015-2016 could not find any kind of
pattern of abuse of force against black
people and furthermore only nine black
people were killed unarmed by the police
shot and killed last year there were 19
whites were unarmed who was shot and
killed by the police last year most
people can't name an unarmed white
person who was killed we can always name
unarmed black people because the media
runs with them in come Van Jones income
CNN in comes MSNBC Hall because it
advanced their narrative that raised in
the remains of major problem in America
when in fact you look at homicides about
half of the homicide victims in this
country been are black and almost all of
these homicide victims were killed by
other black people the the idea that
that cops are mowing down black people
even why Keillor mowing down black
people is simply not borne out by the
facts virtually all the black people who
are killed in this country are killed by
other black people all the interracial
black-white or homicide - there are some
last year there around seven hundred and
fifty five hundred White's were killed
by blacks two hundred and fifty blacks
were killed by whites so right that over
sixty percent the population we're
killing fewer blacks and blacks were at
13% of the population killing whites and
a young black kid is around eight times
more likely to be a homicide victim than
a young white kid in fact the top
preventable cause of death for young
White's is accident like car accidents
the top cause of death where the
preventable or otherwise for young
blacks is homicide almost always at the
hand of another black person in
regarding the cops according to the CDC
in the last forty five fifty five years
police killings of blacks have declined
seventy five percent while police
shootings of wife has flatlined so it is
simply not true
finally it's not like this thing is not
surveyed every two or three years the
government does something called the
police public contact survey and they
had 60,000 Americans did you have
contact with the police last year the
answer is yes tell me about your contact
how will you treat it what we said they
can't find any pattern at all of abuse
against white people it is not true and
just being not true would be neither
here nor there the left leaves a lot of
stupid things but this is not true and
it's getting people killed why because
it angers young blacks and if you're
pulled over and you believe that the
cops are out to get you why should you
have a defensive attitude and all
automatically you create greater great
attention where bad things are more
likely to happen the other thing is on
the part of cops if I'm a cop when I'm
accused of being racist why would I be
proactive I'll just deal with the 911
calls I'm not gonna try and stop crime
not going to look around try and keep
anything look suspicious with the upside
all I'll do is be called a racist so I'm
not doing it so what happens is the cops
go into a roll call the Ferguson effect
which is to become more and more passive
bad guys know it crime goes up in the
very people that the black lives matter
cloud claims they care about are the
ones who are hurt we're all done people
well done
so Larry when when you look at the the
pull differentials by race people
trusting police that the police have
the best interest of the community in
mind among white Americans 77% among
Hispanic Americans and 62% among black
man's Americans it is 36% is this a
reflection of people just swallowing a
media narrative or is this a reflection
of sort of the fact that if there are a
lot of police encounters in your
community you're more likely to have a
negative police encounter or is it or is
it both because it is true that
obviously there are a lot more by
percentage police encounters between
black Americans and members of the
police force then there are in white
communities namely because there's a lot
of crime and among members of the black
community than there are in at least
violent crime then in the white
community well it turns out the numbers
of people that have more than three
contacts in any given year with the
police blacks and whites are about the
same it's about 1.2 black men who had
more than three contacts with the police
in any given year
it's about 1.5 for 1.5 for black men 1.2
for white man so it's not all that
different no I think which which would
drive a narrative Ben is the news I
remember a few years ago there was a
poll in the early times where blacks
were asked how do you sell about your
local police and 80% of blacks had a
positive view about the same as whites
did but then the Rodney King happened
some incidents happened and then it
changes so I think it depends on what's
in the news cycle most black people want
a heavy police presence I have a friend
who's the captain of the California
National Guard and during the second
Rodney King trial in case we went
sideways they deployed the National
Guard in the inner city to make sure
that it would be any violence and he
told me that men and women middle-aged
and older were coming out their homes
coming up to him saying why is it you
guys are only here because you're
anticipating some sort of violence
because of a Riley King jury why aren't
you here every single day we need you
here the majority of people living in
the inner city or hard-working drug
abstaining law-abiding citizens who want
the police to be there so they're loud
mouthed we shall overcome the no justice
no peace types represent a numerical
minority also it's been studied what
happens to communities when you when you
write and you trash the property values
the property values never catch up
incomes never catch up and frequently of
the businesses that are destroyed never
returned and the very same people who do
it and destroyed are now crying racism
because those businesses don't want to
come back and we
bill it's ridiculous what's going on
right now Larry one of the things that
really has has disturbed me is the
unwillingness of anybody to discuss
specific solutions because this is
always what happens in these situations
is that it's much more fun to protest
and shout slogans like black lives
matter in the tacit assumption that for
a lot of people black lines don't matter
right Ashton Kutcher just openly said
that he said well you know the reason we
say black lives matter is because there
are so many Americans who believe they
don't and I just keep looking around
going whoo like seriously who I don't
know a single American black white or
green who doesn't know the name of Ahmed
our Barry or doesn't know the name of
George Floyd or doesn't know the name of
Michael Brown or Freddie gray by the way
not all those cases are the same I mean
a lot of those pieces have differential
fact patterns mean the Michael Brown
case he was actually justifiably shot
according to a jury but you know in the
attempt to avoid specific conversations
in order to pursue a broader narrative
is really disheartening especially
because I know Larry elder you you've
been a libertarian for a long time mean
longer than then I have because I
remember being on your show I was 16
years old I was just getting politically
active and you have been claiming for a
long time that things like police unions
are kind of a problem and and the
doctrine of qualified immunity which
suggests that you are granted immunity
from civil suit if you move beyond your
authority as a police officer you know
the even Clarence Thomas has opposed
that and yet nobody wants to talk about
solutions because we might actually find
some common ground it seems like the
goal here is to not find common ground
well I think one of the reasons Ben
nobody wants talk about solutions is
because you have to have a problem first
if the problem is police brutality
against Blacks it's not true of course
there's no solution for that that's why
people just talk and talk and talk after
Dylan roof killed all those churchgoers
at their church in Charleston I was
watching The Morning Joe show and one of
the presidential candidates martin
O'Malley was on and he was talking about
the institutional racism we need to deal
with we need to deal with we need to
deal with it and one of the core
panelists was a guy named Mike Barnicle
who's a columnist with the with the
Boston newspaper and he said very
innocently wasn't trying to trap him
we're stars for some time he said what
do we do about this Martin and well we
do what we do we have to acknowledge the
work actually Martin III don't know what
you do about this but we need to do
something about it now this guy used to
be mayor of Baltimore 7 or Maryland and
you don't know what to do about the is
socialism that you just now bitched
about and the reason is because it's not
true and if it's not true of course
there's no quote solution for it the
only thing that week that I recommend is
the widespread use of body cams and for
the active this is probably going to
help the cost more than helps going to
help the the civilians there was a city
in California call Rialto one hundred
thousand people have been it is
definitely diverse and the police were
ordered to wear body cams they didn't
want to what they did and after a year
or so guess what happened police
complaints against cops fell ninety
percent because the civilians knew they
were being taped they stopped lying on
the cops police use of force fell fifty
percent not because the police change
their behavior but because the civilians
do it and therefore the police didn't
ever respond to them the point is a lot
of people are lying on cops not unlike
the way Dorian Johnson Michael Browns
friend said Michael Browns at hands up
don't shoot it turned out to be a
complete lie a lot of people are lying
on the cops the cops there's some bad
cops obviously when you have an eight
hundred thousand group of people there's
going to be some bad cops but the idea
that routinely systematically going
after black people is simply not borne
out by the evidence isn't that good news
instead I'm calling Uncle Tom I'm
calling self loathing all sorts of names
instead of people saying well Larry
you're a little naive I wish you were
right but here's why I think you're
wrong I don't get that I see a bunch of
names because people don't want to deal
with the uncomfortable truth that was
going on right now in our society has
nothing to do with what the police are
doing and everything to do with our
failure to take advantage of available
opportunities no larry elder he is the
the author of a boatload of great books
one of them ten things you can't say in
America on New York Times bestseller his
latest documentary is called Uncle Tom
exploring what it's like to be a
conservative black American so Larry
final question for you
the LAPD obviously has for some odd
reason come under a significant scrutiny
I don't know why we have riots and
looting in Los Angeles when this was an
instance of police brutality in
Minneapolis but I guess that's the way
this works now Eric Garcetti our idiot
mayor who has allowed homelessness run
rampant throughout the city decided
there would be a good idea to allow the
the looting to just take place across
the city allow cop cars to be burned and
and to face it will allow Melrose
boulevards basically become a trash heap
I'll allow Fairfax to have all sorts of
stores broken in
- and luden and now he is saying that he
once got 150 million dollars from the
police budget so I'm really optimistic
about the direction of the city how are
you feeling about it you know I have a
two step plan to save California illegal
aliens deport the Democrats this is a
state as you know that run by Democrats
there's a single Republican elected
statewide they don't have this
majorities in the Senate and the
assembly they have super majorities so
they don't even need Republicans and
this is what happens this is the endgame
when you have a state that's run totally
by Democrats the budget is out of
control
almost this is out of control the price
of a home is probably 50% higher than it
would be but for the regulations
according to Lee Ohanian from UCLA from
so we have I'm not optimistic either I'm
not optimistic at all I think sooner or
later however checks have to bounce we
have a 1.5 trillion dollar unfunded
pension liability sooner or later Ben
checks are going to bounce and then
maybe just maybe people who didn't begin
to rethink but until then I'm not
terribly hopeful larry elder again check
out who showed larry elder show and his
author of the book 10 things you can't
say in america among other great books
his latest documentary is called the
Uncle Tom Larry thanks for your time
great stocks you did and and then you
are one magnificent man I don't know if
people realize what a Renaissance person
you are a musician a writer you've
written plays I saw you I saw you
playing the violin incredible pleasure
brilliant I mean then you're the only
person who speaks faster than I do
I appreciate it Larry go check out his
documentary Uncle Tom and check out his
show as well Larry is an American
institution
I hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content